um today i want to talk a little bit
about
self-healing tests motivation what
motivated me why i have even
investigated into the topic first i want
to make a statement
this is software or test automation is
software development hopefully everyone
is in this opinion if not we can
definitely have a great discussion
afterwards in the q a
but for now test automation is software
development this means it needs to be
sustainable it needs to be maintained it
needs to be refracted it needs to get
the same attention as business related
code yeah this is very important
and maintenance especially um maybe you
know or that this is
yeah
expensive
sometimes disgusting annoying and of
course i want to decrease this
maintenance effort
and if you get the test reports yeah
from
the test execution from the test
automation from the pipeline maybe and
you have then you have some failing
tests and you have to do the root cause
analyzing yeah and this is very time
consuming and especially if you have
then some patterns there you see for
example a locator change in something
like this
then this is really annoying yeah and i
was like come on there has to be a
solution outside or where i have to do
things same uh repeat myself yeah
because i'm really
uh
automate practitioner something like
this yes i really want to automate
things where i see i i repeat it
and so i started to research
and
here i found some numbers some
quite
well-known companies like gartner and
also telerik telerik is a company they
did a research on test automation back
best practices and also maintenance and
they published some numbers
and the first number i found which was
maybe the most important one
it's quite big
73.5
of all failing tests are cost of brand
locators or a bad locator strategy yeah
and this is a very huge number with a
huge potential because this is exactly
where self-healing tests um is we are
working against it and i definitely want
to decrease this number
the next two numbers are more related to
automation
the first is 40 percent and here we talk
about uh this is kind of a trend in 2023
40 of all teams or it teams will use
some machine learning or even ai
algorithms to get
more
agility to
achieve more agility and scalability
so this is kind of a trend where we see
a lot of things we get automated and
also some touring will uh support us
here the next number is even much higher
it's 90 percent and this is really
interesting um this is from gartner they
say that 90 percent of all i t companies
will have a dedicated job pro called
uh
that's already
automation architect or automation
engineer something like this and then
you have a reference number today it's
about 20 yeah so this is a
a big trend there and my topic with
self-healing test is really in the
automation part of course
uh and test automation
gartner went even further this is quite
interesting they invented a new term
called hyper automation
what is hype automation
in my words hyper automation is the
orchestration for the automation yeah so
it's kind of you have an effective
combination of a complementary set of
tools
to
so at the end to achieve or to scale
your automation yeah with tactical and
also strategic goals so it's kind of you
orchestrate your automation because you
have quite a lot of automation tools in
place
and at some point in time you have to
orchestrate it
and i did a google trend research on
that and you see some peaks in the past
don't ask me what that this is but since
2019 you see that there is a trend
ongoing
people are searching for that so this is
um you see hypoth mesh is trendy
and self-healing test is um has to do
with with hyper automation
so this is what we motivated me so i
wanted to decrease maintenance effort
and
doing the research i saw that okay this
is a hot topic so there must be a
solution but before i come to the
solution i want to share the problem
and look at this picture look how old i
look at that picture no just kidding
that's not me but maybe i look like that
if i
again doing root cause analyzes and i
find the exception with
no such element yeah so the problem what
i tackling today is the no such element
exception
what is this no such element exception
and maybe you know it but still i want
to explain it
it's a common exception in in gui
testing for example if you use selenium
and
the your automation scripts are not able
to to get the element on the website so
it's not visible or it's um you have
some latency problems or yeah the
locator changed and
you know i mean application changes
after each release more or less yeah and
in days where we release very very fast
the application continuously changes
and
people change here and they can if you
get new people into the team and you
maybe have don't have very good common
agreements or even that you kind of
force it
then they can change locators they can
invent new naming conventions
and if you have a very mature devops
team you can of course predict a lot
that in the communication but you know
sometimes the common communication
between testers and developers is not
that well or even you use
external software components like you
have in your website um i don't know
facebook like buttons and something like
this or other plugins uh those locators
you don't have in your control and if
they change of course you have to do
something yeah
so this is exactly the problem
and for that i searched for the solution
and the solution
is of course i spoiled it already
on my on my title yeah it's self-healing
yeah so self-healing tests
what is self-feeling what what what do i
talk area
and overall you can say that
self-healing is the automation for the
test automation yeah so self-healing
there is um running a process
in your your on your server in your test
automation and it um
fetches data yeah or it's grabs data
so additional data if about the system
about the objects about your website
and stores it and based on this data
it will learn so this also means how
more often you execute and run the stuff
the more the data gets produced and the
better the learning algorithms can work
and can then deliver you then solutions
or self-heal self-healed
locators in in my area now
and at the end it's kind of a key to
build an efficient test automation
and test automation maintenance process
yeah so this is very very important and
this
sounds really cool
so
you know that the problem now and
there's a solution
and then i started of course researching
about
tools here
and
as you all know nowadays it's it's it's
a mess a tool mess outside if you search
for something you get so many tools and
and somehow it's it's really difficult
to choose one
and so there are
several commercial tools like from
marble test i am or tresentis there's of
course no product pitch here it's just
that you hear some numbers
some numbers and companies
and
i as i called myself developer by heart
like really like open source stuff and i
found one yeah and this is called
helenium it's open source
and yeah you can see here the github
link everything is published
and yeah this is really cool and what is
selenium well let me explain it
helenium is open source as already
mentioned and it's based on selenium and
java and so this is kind of was also
precondition if you want to use it
and it's a real time engine what do i
mean with that this is really cool it it
runs with your test execution so nothing
has to be installed on any
server or something like this the
integration is done
in the test automation suite so it runs
with it it's a library
and it of course it needs some
infrastructure based on behind i will
explain you afterwards it has this
machine learning algorithm in place so
it consumes tons of data kind of and
learns
yeah i have not investigated how the
algorithm is designed i also don't care
to be honest it has it in place
and for the developers which is quite
cool they have an intellij idea plugin
which is also easier than for the
maintenance if
if some healing is ongoing that you see
the results and then you can use them
the integration how is the integration
done it's really easy as i mentioned
nothing has to be stored on the server
also on the test execution service
the integration is done on the locators
so if you use
locators like find buy or buy there's a
i guess
mostly common used locators
then you can use helium because the
integration is done a level higher so
it's done on the web driver and you can
see it here so in general you have here
your web driver your chrome browser you
also use a chrome and then based on that
you can create the cell filling driver
and then this drive you can use it
afterwards for your locators yeah so
this is how the integration is done of
course you need some configuration files
and so on there you'll
tell the
helenium where the backend servers are
and so on but these are
yeah
details
this is just what you have to prepare
and as i mentioned this property failed
so this is
what the name is about now i want to
explain you also
how helium is designed from the
components that it's really transparent
because um yeah for me it took
i don't know
one or two hours to install everything
that was really cool yeah
so what is telling you uh how selenium
the components are first
everything starts with test automation
code if you don't have the test
automation code you should maybe
investigate that and invest in test
automation it pays off
here you have to integrate it with your
helium client so it's kind of the helium
jar yeah so this is what you have to do
then you have more or less everything
done from this integration perspective
and what you have to of course install
is a helenium back-end this is a rest
for web service
and it yeah you can install it by your
own or they have a docker support so you
can run it inside a docker which is very
convenient so you just have to yeah pull
the dock image and run it
and of course it needs a database so
this is kind of the helenium pulse quest
database see everything is here also
free
and this is also um
delivered by a docker image so
nothing
um
intensive to configure
and for those are really lazy like
me
they also support or deliver a docker
compose file
so you just have to download this
um yammer file and then start it and
both of these docker images get started
and you can interact with it through the
rest for web service so this is
from that perspective two things are
missing
on the one side as i mentioned the
intellij id plugin yeah this of course
you can download from the marketplace
it's integrated with the automation code
yes of course and with the rest for web
service
so this is from that perspective but
that's optional and also for the
reporting they have a gradle and a maven
plugin because they need to tell the
back end when the new test execution
is done or triggered that they can
deliver a better report but also that is
optional they don't have to use it
and
yeah
so that's the component smallest
as i mentioned everything very easy
straightforward and
easy to use
good as next point i want to and this is
now kind of the
most exciting one i prepared an example
yeah did you really see various selenium
working how
what did you get and so on and
here i prepared uh the example
again with an open source project yeah i
guess you see a pattern and this is a
digibank it's a digital bank app
also on github and yeah i just
prepared your test case for
for the login
good so as i mentioned this is our
digibank running
yeah it's a website you can see here our
test automation framework you can see
here um this is the helenium backend
they're so very sophisticated now here
and
this is defined by a locator so you can
see here this is not with the password
and you can see here kind of the snippet
of the html you can see oh yeah that's
the input the id is password so
everything is fine
good now you know we have a pipeline
tests are always executed so it gets
triggered what did the desktop um
automation framework tries to find the
element
and it
has found the element cool everything is
nice
but this status are quite difficult to
read maybe
this successfully found um gets also um
transported to the helium jar and this
gets also then forwarded to the helenium
back end there it stores all the
additional data
so nice
cool
so in your
test execution you see a green
uh
green sign everything is fine
good now new version newer version comes
that's
yeah usual and yeah they implemented new
naming conventions if this is now
realistic or not um they don't care but
the new name equation for the attribute
id there was another html time
so password gets password input
okay good they of course deploy
everything um and the test get executed
it tries to find the element yeah and of
course what happens now
[Music]
bam
exactly
uh no such element exception but this is
now in the locks so you don't get that
because
helium is in place and
this stratos element not found or not
such element gets forwarded again to the
helium client this gets forwarded to the
back end there the algorithm starts
working and it delivers
new locators
and these locators get then forwarded
again to the test execution
and it tries to refine the element and
you also can define refined counters and
so on how often you should try it
and
it forms a little bit awesome but why
what's in the logs here and if you go
inside you can see that it's first it in
the red box it uh
um
first
use the password one there so this then
it tries to heal
and you see it's use the heat locator
now with a score of 79 something i don't
know what that is
yeah maybe this is the algorithm yeah
and it used the css selector input
password yeah so with id again so that's
very interesting so it doesn't only take
historical data it also takes the data
from the current run which is really
nice
and of course an id has a very high
value if i would remove the id now it
would probably take the name yeah
or i don't know most probably and this
is really cool yeah so also if i locate
the changes it tries to take the new one
and
yeah the oops sorry and the test is
green yeah so you don't see it the test
is green
you're just in the report you would see
that it healed it
but from the execution perspective
everything is fine
good
awesome two things are missing as i
already mentioned report and again the
id plugin first the report
the report is available um
also from from this
rest for web server but here you get
delivered a gui
and
from each execution you get in the hilt
report and you can see here where nicely
uh what was the failed locator so you
can see um the password and id
and then also the healed one and a nice
picture next to it and also kind of a
toggle where you can see if it's
successful or not i guess this is then
that the algorithm learns from it a
little bit better the viewers can tell
it um that it didn't work
uh but i have not tested that one
um
yes
cool
from a recommendation from my
perspective that this report is a little
bit it's nice but i would integrate it
into your current reporting whatever
you're using um maybe to also implement
the new status yeah
because um in general you have the green
ones and the red ones yeah so the
successful tests and then the the failed
ones
and i highly recommend to implement the
search start those kind of orange one
where it's kind of the heat locators
yeah you can get this data out of this
server
and
that you see it yeah because
it's quite nice to have this
really
but also it's very nice to use it
for a discussion with the developers
that is telling hey guys or in the next
grooming or in the retro or wherever you
want yeah
then hey guys why we have 10 uh heal
locators yeah why you have changed them
because of course you want to
you want to use it that
also not only for healing but also as a
discussion
basement
and how does the intellij
plugin look like this is like this so
you have here your source code and you
can do a right click on the locators you
have the healing results um in the
context menu and if you click there you
have then or locators healed once from
that
so you can see the second one is this id
password input with the score 79
and the other one is i i don't know that
one to be honest
uh
yeah good so cell feeling
what is self-feeling
self-healing is
the automation for test automation
self-healing saves time in maintenance
of the automation script
self-healing
source definitely the no such element
exception
and self-healing with open source means
helenium
and if you ask me now is self-filling
nowadays holy grail for test automation
difficult question yeah i would say yeah
yeah
it's the right way i really like i mean
you see that automation hype automation
there it's it's a high trend it's a hot
topic and with helenium you you don't
have a huge border to get into that yeah
it's open source you can really fast
start it of course if you're using java
and selenium and you can use it to get
first experiences in this area yeah i
really like it
it's it's maybe not the holy grail yep
but it's definitely one of the right
steps into the right direction i really
enjoyed it it was a really nice
experience for my side i learned a lot
and
yeah
that's what i can say to that